[Music]
a Bachelor Winter Games
premieres tonight with tears for an
entirely different reason and here's why
it may just be the best bachelor
spin-off yet Winter Games is going to be
cold
sexy dramatic unpredictable and
international first up we get to meet 14
fresh faces from bachelor international
and the hoax are representing Germany
Germany and Switzerland 34 year old
Christian and airport worker turned
model was on The Bachelorette in Germany
and then again in Switzerland when a
woman looks beautiful I like it also
bringing the heat Canadian firefighter
Kevin who's a Tom Brady doppelganger I
would love to win something to hang on
my wall is there a big rose trophy guys
to Winter Games and while we're excited
to see returning bachelor nation faves
like luke pal Ben Higgins and Dean
Englert before in accents are everything
hello means I mean that's whenever you
resign crush angel Shah Pahlavi Emmons
true nerd site moment German isn't
exactly the sexiest language but
whatever Christian says sounds sexy
unlike the other shows of the franchise
Winter Games doesn't take itself too
seriously putting less pressure on a
proposal at the end but with contestants
competing for coveted date cards that
drama will be even more intense they can
be pretty hot-headed and bullheaded if
somebody crosses or pisses me off
oh and who doesn't love a good wipeout I
look ridiculous I'm like bang they are
eyes and with only four to our episodes
fans will wish winter lasted a little
longer
[Music]
frickin crazy right house
[Music]